it is stunning to me that the majority
of people that are watching this right
now have firstworldproblems
I see so many young people rightfully so
in it and makes me admire them be so
altruistic yet they're so weak inside
themselves they act as though they want
to help the world as a way to build
confidence a facade it's ego and that's
fine and it's a lot better than other
things so I don't judge it's just I
wasn't able to give this much back until
I scratched a couple things for myself
I'm starting to write because because I
just well I think they're fine I know
right now you've got a try stuff
the biggest reason you don't know what
you want to do is you haven't tasted
enough things and the biggest reason
you're not tasting enough things is
you're worried about finding it too fast
it's patience austenite it's patience
it's you can't be lost in life when
you're this young you just have to
change your mindset like to me when I
look around this many people being in
their 20s like everybody's judging
themselves way too early what I would do
is gather as many experiences as
possible almost everything is
perspective like I think I think I'm
just starting so imagine what I think
for most of you
patience patience you know whether it's
your parents or yourself or people
everybody's trying to prove something so
early
too many people viewed post University
as like oh [ __ ] this is now real and
lost they don't put it in the context of
being alive for a hundred years and
realizing they're only 20% of the way
done everybody's got strengths and
weaknesses what what a 60 year old has
is experienced but doesn't have time so
they trade on experience what youth has
is time you can literally do four
different things over the next two years
six months at a time to figure out
everything that you think you might like
you should try to do but that's not what
people tell you to do you're not lost in
life you're just early in the process
you know what I mean you're lost by
other people's standards not by your
actual if you actually took it
practically you're you haven't even
started
[Music]